Harris they found the missing girl Katy  Nelson yeah I heard about that this  morning  but you got a telly O'Neil there's a  real missing girl that's me alright five  guys definitely in my life the first one  Joshua got a spatula and punched me in  the boob  second one Patrick he got his motorcycle  and ran over my stuffed animal and there  was Geoffrey  you got my play-doh and shoved it up my  butt and there then there was  then there was Heath and he got the  Bologna that I love and threw it in the  lake and the worst one was his mic he  found my lucky handkerchief in my drawer  and yo D did he wrapped it around his  [ __ ]  anyway it's great they found my missing  girl though yeah